so does that mean that like the vast
majority of your real wealth creation
has been in like the 10 last 10 years no
in the last like
a few years but you weren't you you were
broke I was I would consider myself
broke I would say I started from zero
almost in 2016 when I launched the
machine I wouldn't say Deadpool I mean
you're a millionaire you would you were
you worth at least 10 I would say I was
probably worth like you know 15 or 20 in
that film so not broke but to me I was
like bro to a future billionaire a
millionaire is broke
[Music]
laughs
Sean say exactly what you just said to
me when we finished our recording with
Rob Dyrdek I said I think that was the
best episode of MFM we've ever done uh I
I don't know I don't know if I'm just on
a high right off of it but I believe so
people can tell in the YouTube comments
they should tell us I to me this was the
best episode we've done 400 something
episodes how many have you done Jonathan
something like 400 episodes that was the
number one my favorite the best episode
we've ever done the from beginning to
end I'm shocked so like you asked him we
started getting along really well and
you said Rob what's your net worth and I
was like damn is he gonna answer that
and he gave the full answer We're not
gonna say it now but it's somewhere in
the middle somewhere but he gave the
entire answer where he broke it down he
talked about his I'm just actually
shocked that he said most of the things
that he said and it was amazing in a
great way stories of two companies that
he's built and the stories were
phenomenal uh we talked about net worth
what he does with his money how he
thinks about investing we talked about
like how he kind of went from
beginner at business and making all the
mistakes to now being really
sophisticated and how that all happened
a really short amount of time we talked
about his his house the forever estate
the dream that he's been building around
and how he does it was we we touched it
hit all the buttons had the
inspirational the Tactical the uh
entertaining the humorous it had
everything that I like in an episode but
in one so I'm I'm I couldn't be happier
right now so if you use YouTube whether
you're listening on on podcasts or
you're actually watching us right now
let us know in the comments what you
think or if you're not a YouTuber just
tweet at Sean and I it's uh Sean VP like
vice president Sean VP and then thus
sampar and add Rob to it and let us know
uh in Twitter on Twitter or if you're a
YouTuber let us know there I'm very
curious what you guys think and uh tag
Rob if you can give us a wave of
feedback I'm gonna send it all to Rob
after after the Pod to to show him uh
the the love because I know people are
gonna love this all right without any
further build up here's the episode
episode with Rob Dyrdek
uh all right we're live Rob we uh Sean
you missed it because you're late you're
always late and that's dear that's his
whole thing is timeliness and he was
talking mad [__] about you because you
were using his face and his time
template that he talked about in the
last pod I am human optimization was the
big the line from his last time he was
on that's been I think it's like in our
trailer now and uh Rob if you are human
optimization I am human on optimization
I am the opposite yeah and hey look the
beauty of the
you know time Mastery is you don't
you're also it's time flexibility and
understanding that life is this living
experience but nothing brings me Greater
Joy than to know a man that was using my
time data for customer acquisition and
knowing that how much I collect my data
and how how specific I am with mastering
my time would be seven minutes to have
me waiting for seven minutes makes it
even more it makes life more Grand to me
to know that for you knowing how much I
respect and use my time so thoughtfully
that you would steal a little bit from
me even you know what I mean it's very
fun okay that is well played I
appreciate that dude we were talking
about a bunch of stuff before you hopped
in Rob I want to talk about that in a
second but you came on I think two years
ago or a year and a half ago I don't
remember that was like your first
everyone I just reread the comments a
minute ago everyone said the same [__]
which is the exact same thing I thought
which was Rob's just a skater uh he's
he's smart and does good TV [__] and all
that stuff but we didn't realize that he
was just profound and that pod I felt
like one is your what it does you're
coming out as like this like human
optimization thing now I've watched you
with so many other people and you've
I've gone more in depth on some of your
stuff
is that true was that like your first
time like was that like the the artist
formerly known as Prince moment
you guys get all the credit thank you
that's what I was looking for hey
because because let me give you this you
led out with trying to talk to me about
you did you did no depth of research
into seeing what I was up to you let out
with some skate talk and TV talk and
then I went on like a 20-minute rant to
un so that you could understand the
depth of how I operate yeah then the
entire conversation changed for an hour
you know what I mean and that that that
to me is like the funniest part of the
experience was I said okay they didn't
even they have no idea who they're
talking to let me let me lay this out
real quick and and but again I I'm so
thankful that you guys the conversation
turned to because it was also like I had
been collecting the data using my rhythm
of existence but I'd never shared it
before so even then sharing it with you
and then you guys reposting it it really
began to like create the wave and then
you guys put out a
a little thing that was about what if
Rob how would Rob monetize his data and
so you put out this entire thing about
like how uh to build an app and and what
I would need to charge in order to
create a business out of it and it
really started the wheels in me of like
like realizing that man I need to turn
this philosophy first into then a usable
digital product that's more intuitive
that's deeper than an app that's
actually a software that allows people
to realize this level of Harmony and
overall happiness that I've created
through this system and which has led to
where I'm at today of continually
pushing the philosophy forward and
ultimately creating a software was
inspired by you guys
we get all the credit that's nice
there's actually a couple listeners who
after they heard that made their version
they were like dude who was talking
about this it sounded so awesome he said
he might share it but we haven't seen it
yet so I just went ahead and I made my
own version it's it's linked to Google
Sheets it was kind of a janky version
but I definitely inspired several people
to I mean many people to to look in
order to be like you know how am I
treating my time and it seems like you
had the kind of the complete balance you
were like I have my time that's with my
wife and my kids and then I have my work
time and then I have my body you know
you had it all so I think that
definitely inspired a lot of people to
look at it but it also inspired some
people to try to build their own version
of that tracker so that they could have
the kind of the you know the what gets
measured gets managed that type of
attitude around around their time yeah
and again I think it's it's so much more
complex than that right because time's
alive and your time and experience your
present basically your whole life leads
to this present moment in time and then
the energy that you feel at this present
and moment in time is ultimately the
quality of your reality that you're in
right so time ends up being this much
much more important aspect of learning
to manage and then you're changing all
the time the world's changing you're
selling companies you're starting new
companies your kids are growing all
these things so like managing your time
and how you stay balanced is constantly
changing as well as you change so it's
this ongoing focus in my life that it's
this Con constant assessment and and
adjustment to lead me towards a better
probability of a better future
experience and that's what's difficult
when somebody makes their own app
there's sort of a philosophy and a
rhythm and a process that I think I need
to that I'm creating in the software
that makes it much more intuitive based
off of the type of personality you have
and the way your life rolls to get it to
actually work because otherwise it just
feels like you're making checklists and
and making data and then it gets too
difficult and it's over you know before
you join Sean we're talking about Andrew
huberman and the reason why we're
talking about them is because
but I I like to skate Rob is a skater
hardcore obviously professional
skateboarder and heberman loves it and
we were talking about that and I don't
know if you know what momentous is Sean
but it's like they're they're one of the
main advertisers on the heberman Pod and
they're and it's Andrew huberman says
like this is the only protein that I
like so obviously I bought a ton that's
what I drink every day and Rob was like
and I is it Jeff is he the CEO I'm
supposed to talk to Jeff Jeff is the CEO
yeah yeah yeah I'm supposed to talk to
Jeff because Ken Ridout introduced us
who was also on the Pod and anyway uh
Rob was like yeah yeah you know that's
cool it's amazing to see what how past
that business grew because of huberman's
uh you know promotion you know you know
I co-founded that company not too long
ago and it's just crazy how fast it's
grown and we are like wait what Rob you
co-founded momentous protein
yeah and look in in and here's the thing
with momentous protein I co-founded it
with Matt Wan in 2016.
um the when they brought it to me he had
a vision for creating basically the most
premium supplements that the market had
ever seen the Ferrari of supplements it
was called project one at the time and
um Matt was foregoing his first year of
Harvard to build this company he was 18
years old and his father uh Mark Juan
had been one of the big investors in my
professional skateboarding league so I
had a relationship with him and said you
know I would do this project with his
son first thing we had to do was Rebrand
it right and really like create a name
and a soul into what is the absolute
Pinnacle of supplements momentous right
and all the way down to where I even you
know went through the whole process of
even making that logo you know like to
me that m is like this Timeless
extraordinary logo and Rob that's you in
photo shop or this is like a creative
agency pitching you guys how does that
happen you take it make it this is
literally an illustrator of the agency
sent some logos of me cutting up the
agency's logo and being like no get rid
of there was a circle in the middle I'm
like no this is like look at this it
forms like an m in a mountain like like
get rid like I literally cut and pasting
in my illustrator the momentous logo
love it and so we launched that company
and what happens
we don't sell a thing
we don't sell a thing what do we got we
got the most overpriced
like protein in the entire industry it's
like it's like 35 above like every other
protein like it's like literally nobody
buys it
nobody buys it now you what do you got
you got an 18 year old CEO this kid
doesn't even every single day is another
thing of like oh that's what happens in
business you're you're if you want to
talk about the headwinds of No Man's
Land and the pain of launching a
business with an 18 year old genius
right because he's brilliant but he was
18 and didn't even understand anything
about a company and you can't advise
somebody into running a company you know
what I'm saying you have to fight the
fire learn the battles to ever learn how
to operate a company
long story short
this this business never got off the
ground for years
and I finally now he's older and like
I'm like look man you've got to make a
decision like you've tried everything
you've done all different types of
Partnerships you've made all different
types of verticals of product it is the
Ferrari of supplements it is absolutely
the purest and best you kept it real but
you just can't find a market for it
like you either have to sell it or you
have to find somebody to merge with but
you got to move on like you can't like
spend your You're Now 23 like you
learned everything go figure take this
skill set that you learned and apply it
to a business that has a a more uh
relatively faster growing opportunity
what were the sales what what were the
annual sales when you when you had that
conversation oh I want to say a few
million and just losing money year over
year and how much did you put in yeah
how much did you put into it to start I
put in
um
shoot I want to say not much like 200
000 and the first like like at the
beginning to get it off the ground and
another hundred thousand three hundred
thousand maybe do split Equity when you
do that like and I got 30 of the
business okay okay so so now
um
man raised so much Capital Any Which Way
but Loose you know now I'm on the board
I'm in board meetings like and there's
I'll tell you what nothing nothing is
painful as board meeting after board
meeting when there's no Revenue growth
and you're just burning Capital trying
to figure out how you're going to tell a
story to raise more Capital to keep the
dream alive
um that went on for a significant amount
of time we got incredibly deluded and
then
the it was just like hey man you've got
to make a decision here on like what you
what your life looks like forget about
forget about this company forget about
this investment like you now like are
you you forgoed going to Harvard
to build this company so you essentially
like stepped away from from this big
education which always like in the
beginning I was like this kid's too
smart to go to school what he should
just go start a company he doesn't need
to go to school like as I have kids and
I'm older you know what I mean you know
like seven eight years later I'm like
man I I was like the bad uncle by
advising them to not go to Harvard and
I'll do this company with you gassed him
up right like I I think he should have
went to Harvard in hindsight
um but again
like diluted all the way down he went
out and found uh amped
um the business that Jeff was running at
the time that I actually man I I looked
at in 2015 and almost did a deal to own
half of PR lotion and and the amp
product because of how much I believed
in the IP uh of of what they developed
because it was built through this um uh
biopharma group that I was doing deals
with back in 15. in my early days of
hustling and
they merged and in that merger then they
did a deal now they're joint companies
that the whole company becomes momentous
and then they they lock in that humor
bin deal
and then the business exploded overnight
overnight wow overnight you know do you
know how how much did it grow by like
man
like 20 times right like it like it went
like
um it is it is now like poised to like
now make a real run and I would
attribute it to the one for one
like media to consumer that Andrew
huberman was to the product right so we
could never find an audience it didn't
matter how much like ad spends we did
where we spent it we had deals with NFL
teams and MLB teams and all these
athletes and all this stuff but it was
when it finally landed with someone
whose core media is their authenticity
in
um the science side of human
optimization then he's saying hey Andy's
has this massive platform then he's
saying this is the very best supplements
because they are in fact the very best
supplements when you tie those together
boom that thing goes you know what I
mean that's a Amazing Story what do I
have now I don't know what do I have now
like four percent you know what I mean
like I've been good so now you know call
it nine years later uh or a seven years
later I already gave up on the brand
don't even like claim it like looked at
it when they merged as an exit and now
it's just like completely exploded but
you know and yes I'll get like a return
on my 300 000 that would be significant
um to
you know probably a regular investor but
you know for me in the co-founding game
it could have been you know I looked at
selling that business for 100 million in
under five years and having 20 of it
when I when I measured that out in 16
versus you know selling it eight years
later and making a million dollars
wherever I end up getting deluded on the
end and like okay cool you got like two
and a half times your money but that's
like that's not why you play the game of
venture creation that was I think that
was my perfect so that might be my the
favorite story that's ever been shared
on this pod for a couple reasons one you
told it great two
um
it had it had all the the drama the
elements uh to it and three you're very
honest like um most people that come on
this pod uh were like how much did you
put in they're like ah hand wave we're
like oh it's doing well now and then
they're like yeah it's doing well but
they won't say that last part which like
yeah but you know it's been eight years
I got deluded and honestly I'll make
kind of [__] all on this and and I I I'm
really the game I'm in you know that's
good but the game I'm in is to create
create X very honest I I want people to
appreciate that because that is so we do
we've done 100 plus guests of people
that are from all walks of life people
that are post economic they already made
it they have no incentive to kind of
like to to not fully be honest with with
the situations and uh it is very rare to
hear that so I I really really like that
I got two follow-ups for you on things
you said there the first is you said you
kind of think maybe you should have gone
to Harvard and I think there's an
interesting question that applies to a
lot of people which is like should I go
to college I kind of feel like you know
people who make it they're like ah you
know that's not where you learn it you
learn it in the real world it sounds
like you were kind of in that boat but
you said maybe you changed your mind as
you've matured or with your own kids
what what's the thinking there what is
it he should have gone to Harvard
because the company wasn't working or
you came to appreciate something else
about the value of college I think I've
come to appreciate the value of college
above all and as someone who quit High
School
and started his first company at 17. you
know what I mean like I'm I think about
this but do you appreciate college or
Harvard and top 20 colleges well Harvard
obviously has a higher level of like
Prestige but but what I never understood
even back then
was the looking at business in a
multi-dimensional way learning
everything about business understanding
product and and supply chain
understanding brand and marketing and
customer customer acquisition
understanding uh sort of management and
hiring and teams like all of this uh
diff and understanding sales and then
understanding operational side really
understanding the financial side knowing
that all of those have to integrate into
a financial model that you've got to
believe you can execute because that's
how a business actually becomes
successful is when you project what
you're going to do and you actually do
it not project a fantasy uh so you can
raise money right and I think that going
to business school you at least uh leave
with the fundamentals of that and and
have a general knowledge that when you
step out into the real world and really
try to build a company you're you're at
least going to have a foundation of what
you're launching off of versus what he
did what I did when I was launching all
these companies when I was young all the
way into my 30s or what he did at 18
years you have such little general
knowledge of how it all works because
you're such an optimist especially when
you're really smart you can figure
things out fast but there's just too
many things that you don't know when it
comes to like the complexities of
building something like a business right
and then uh my second question was do
you uh this is a little nerdy on the
protein side but how did you actually go
about creating the cleanest supplement
because I've thought about this many
times which is uh there is definitely a
market for people who want this the
highest quality purest grade best best
for you products they'll pay the extra
20 bucks per bag to get it
um and when you you look I think the
supplement industry is notoriously dirty
like uh you know the places where they
make stuff you know it's if you test
these things they don't turn out very
well so did you guys do anything radical
to actually achieve that result or was
it just finding the right partner and
then that was it it was it was first
like the people who helped develop it
right we're all like trainers and uh for
the 49ers and the Celtics right then
um it's all the certifications that make
the
um I can't think of their exact name
like grass and info sport whatever these
intersport whatever they may be but
these certifications that are very
expensive
right so now like the layer of edit what
does that do the man it just keeps
putting pressure on price and margin
right because there's just a certain
point where it's like man it's so
expensive more expensive do even the
people that really care isn't making
enough of a difference
right for the absolute premium and to me
absolutely we'd find a consumer and that
consumer never showed up until huberman
said to that audience which converted
Sam and now has Sam talking to Jeff like
you it's like that level of authenticity
the product backed that up but it we
never found that level of media that
could validate it to reach a large
enough consumer base that would be
willing to pay that extra amount of
money it's a dice roll when you when you
launch a business to do it like that you
know we need to get in the certification
business I think yeah that sounds like
the real business
this is cruelty free certified Inc yeah
we will we will certify everything for
y'all for for the low low price by the
way it's funny that like Joe Rogan is
like bro Oprah but now tuberman is like
Dr Phil or Dr Oz or something like of
the of this kind of like the guy media
game where it's the the doc if the doc
says this is the way to go if he says
this is clean you know he can move a lot
of product like an unbelievable amount
of product in a short amount of time but
look you think about it's like when you
think about the depth of him and how he
approaches it like you know how deep it
is
so it's like he's earned that respect
from you and and so it's like you don't
have to you don't question whether or
not Nike's going to put as much effort
and Innovation as they possibly can into
a running shoe you don't even look into
the technology you pick the color and
which one feels the good you know that
they're going to do all the work to get
it there developing that level of
authenticity is incredibly difficult you
know because there's a lot of other
people that are huberman-esque
that do not have his depth which in turn
does not allow or his process that you
believe in which in turn doesn't allow
them to carry the same weight that he
does and that was probably just a
straight cash deal when you guys bought
that ad spot I would imagine right yeah
I'm not entirely sure I was involved in
the company at that point I'm not I'm
not entirely sure what the what his deal
is
um but whatever it is
he got underpaid
whatever it is hey whatever
it was too little
look I am not privy to what it is but
whatever it is they got a deal you know
what I mean like I just know that what
what are some other uh Venture creation
that you've been up to so that was one
amazing adventure creation story you got
me hungry for another do you got any
other interesting things you've been
cooking and how many have how many have
you even done have you done you've done
dozens of these yeah I've done a bunch
I've done a bunch you know what I mean
and and that's and here's the beauty of
it too is like I've made so much money
right that I'm you can play the game
more honest right which in your you're
not really you're judging yourself off
of your irr but you are not like once
you get to a certain point like you're
playing the game for the speed of the
irr and the scale of the IR and its
potential because when I started the
game I wanted to build 50 to 70
companies uh and make
you know uh own uh 25 to 35 and sell
them for between you know 50 million and
150 million and make 20 to 30 each but
when you know you sell a company for 200
million and get you know 150 million you
you're like well that's way more fun
like how do I how do I move this number
from like making you know 15 to 30
million a deal to like you know 50 to
200 million a deal right you just begin
to change as you're sort of evolving and
what do less deals you want to do less
deals right and then you you want to be
much more focused on the opportunity and
then
like focused on all the Lessons Learned
would I start a supplement brand with an
18 year old ever again I would not you
know what I mean like and so let me give
you an example of an opposite version
right so
um I was approached by a really really
uh seasoned CEO who had just built a
company and sold it was a footwear brand
called greats okay so I also owned a
pair of those man right so so you
understand him is a brand and him is a
brand Builder and as a CEO like you know
and he had an idea he wanted to share
with us and it was in the beauty space
and he essentially presented to us this
concept of
um filtered shower water is this
overlooked Cornerstone of creating your
beauty routine like your water is filled
with all this garbage that dries out
your hair and dries out your skin it
does all this stuff yet for some reason
there's no no one's approached Beauty
and filtering the water right so we do
all the and again so okay wow this is
super interesting then now you look at
it from a business model right then it's
like oh wow now it's reoccurring Revenue
so it's a single bit of Hardware that
now the filters have to be replaced so
now you've got this reoccurring Revenue
now it's a super experienced CEO that as
as a depth of knowledge in in DTC so
it's not like you know a lot of times
you'll find a a an experienced CEO that
came from retail who just oh it's I want
to build an Amazon business right
because retail's so hard like anytime
you find people trying to transition to
what they think is an easier way to
create meals uh is always a red flag but
it but again now he has the the
understanding the knowledge and now it's
like is this space ballot
so we do the research what do we do we
go and look at the entire space of all
of the filtered shower heads the entire
Market it is tiny tiny tiny under a
billion dollars right and he wants to
charge 135 dollars for the unit 35
dollars for the filters you know you can
go to Home Depot and get a shower filter
for like
19 bucks you know there's like one
Premier premium one that's sold by a
beauty company that's you know kind of
chromey or whatever that's like 99 100
but like no movement
and so when you look at that opportunity
you look at it like it's as clear as can
be where it's like man this is either
Pure White space
and there is a real opportunity to like
make this matter in Beauty and make a
massive business and
or
it will like literally just not work it
is like so pure but then the tantalizing
side is well boy if it works man it's
like think of the friction it takes to
get a shower head in but man think of
how low the churn will be on the
subscription because it'll be way more
friction to to take it completely out to
stop your uh reoccurring like
subscription every two months then it
will and put back your old shower head
like that made it this incredibly
compelling concept and and by the way
for the listener this is basically your
shower head so I don't even I don't even
think most people know this but the
shower head it's not that hard to remove
you can kind of do it yourself and what
you're and it's Jolie is this Jolie is
that you say it Jolene Jolie and you
basically they give you or because I've
seen this company they killed it in year
one I think they did four million in
sales in the first year you basically
they send you a thing a new shower head
you they send you a wrench you put it on
there and then you put little like
filters and packets and I think they
smell nice or something like that and
they might have some type they might
have some type of other good stuff in
there but the the premise is is that uh
for all the really hardcore Health nerds
they're afraid of some of the chemicals
and minerals that are in city water and
so they want this to be better
um and I have friends that have like um
what's that one uh like charcoal water
filter that's made out of metal that
ever they do that for their home like
they do these really like ten thousand
dollar projects for their home and what
this product is is that for a shower
head did I summarize that and think if
that's correct and it's the efficacy of
it right and then how did they launch
the company how were they able to go to
4 million and now this year you know
they'll do close to 40 million is that
they
um
they opened it up by like putting in
your ad your your ZIP code so you could
see all the contaminants in your water
nice so how they did all their initial
customer acquisition is they got all the
data of what it because the sit the the
water departments have to report all the
contaminants in the water and so they
scraped all that data you put in your
zip code and then you got
um a complete report of all the stuff in
your water that's how they did customer
acquisition for months before they even
had the product out
you know what I mean then they did
pre-orders before it launched right then
what were we all hanging on for what's
that first quarter of churn the churn
was at like you know 1.2
like of the subscription it's like
everything about it and then it was just
growth month of a month of a month then
like they just keep evolving like they
launched an erwan in the grocery store
they have a giant display and you can
buy them an erwan right the it's like
the entire process of how they did it
overnight because you got to think how
do you value a business like that that
that that business is valued at 200
million plus
in a year and a half because how are you
how do you really look at that where
it's like yes it's selling Hardware
month over month but then it is stacking
subscription dollars
like so it is it is this extraordinary
Hardware subscription service that is
incredibly rare that has made it so
valuable overnight he built the company
with three people we're the primary
investor it's profitable and never
raised another dime ever again
chef's kiss what size check you do on
that one yeah I did 800 in that one
so that's I mean that's that's
substantial right for an early stage
startup I mean you know I will I'll go I
go I'm all over the place but I'll go up
to 10 million you know what I mean so
when I think 800 I think it's like kind
of small what's been the biggest bet
like where where have you plowed in
something like 10 million into what type
of bet was that I did you know when I uh
my professional skateboarding League my
production company
uh merged in with Nitro Circus and
created thrill one media
and then we sold 301 media for 300
million right of which uh we got 200
million right and this was sort of like
the layering in of my production deal
and then the group that bought 301 I
invested 10 million with them to buy me
um as
and then did a separate deal as it
relates to having a bigger stake in the
production company uh that I sold and my
league and the overall Sports property
um because I knew
um during that that transaction I knew I
was going to negotiate for a bigger
television deal so I basically leveraged
um you know my ability to go and get a
lot of value for the company so I got
all this Equity back they just paid me
you know close to 200 million so I used
10 of it and to invest in buying me so
that I could you know turn around and
hopefully make another you know you know
not not nearly as much but hopefully
like another like 100 to 150 off of it a
couple years down the line and when you
say we is that like Deirdre family
office or is that uh right you don't
have a fund right yeah it's just your
family office just my money yeah like no
I this is all my money so I and I just
run it like a family office and I just
look at that as where I would deploy
Venture Capital right so if I just
deploy Capital into real estate and
Ventures that I have a much more control
over and or I have a higher leverage or
position uh but it was amazing think
about this like in the closing of the
deal I had to not I it was the most
money I made in one shot right and the
most like I had invested it once an
adventure so with the like here on my
you know closing that deal in the zoom
call it was the most I made and the most
I invested in in one uh one one here
here with you know whatever like I
whatever my like final check off on was
it but again what are the stakes of it
it's whatever you know what I mean I
look at it as it's fun and like I'm
underwriting the business because I went
and signed a massive television deal so
I'm under underwriting that entire roll
up like and it's amazing Partners it's
Dana White and the Fertitta family who
own the UFC so it's like even being
close to them and knowing them for so
long uh just makes the joy of of even
partnering with them fun and exciting
and I dedicate very little time to it
right like I I still
um and help help sort of adding the
vision and how to continue to evolve and
grow it but I you know continue to shoot
television
at an even much higher scale like now
I'm shooting 336 episodes a year up from
um that's still at four percent of my
time
um that's you know essentially five
hours a day uh four times a month for 10
months right like is essentially what it
is but it's underwritten the entire roll
up it is you know a billion dollar
television deal over a seven year period
with the production and everything
involved I get all my talent money but
then I'm also leveraged into the roll up
in the production company again to sell
it again
um
and it's it's it's it's just squeezing
water out of a rock you know what I'm
saying it's like you're looking at
opportunities inside every deal you know
there just isn't a world where I'm just
looking at like where are the ways for
me to add leverage create opportunity in
each one of the ways that I look at
every one of these deals
um each and every time who are some of
your business uh advisors mentors
friends that are helping you develop
this muscle because you know you go from
anything you want to do you go from a
white belt to blue belt eventually
you're you can become a black belt and
it sounds like you know when you started
you were more of a white but like
everybody and now you know looking at
structures looking at ways to double dip
looking at ways to um you know measure
okay I want irr but also I should be
thinking about the gross dollar amounts
and maybe fewer deals but bigger deals
who have you learned a ton from that uh
that you you respect either as a friend
or mentor on the business side man I you
know I don't think anybody plays the
game like this that I know that's in my
circle you know I think it's a it's that
experience and it's that like
continually
looking at every deal
multi-dimensionally right and I think
like the gift that I actually had early
on is I used to look at media and
marketing multi-dimensional right so
like in the early days I would you know
be able to look at like a television
show and how are all these ways that I
could monitor monitor monetize it right
like how do I own the rights of media
and then I could sell that to different
people like I always looked at
opportunity multi-dimensionally but I
didn't understand how to build and
create value and business so I never
looked at business multi-dimensionally
and I just think I'm at once I taught
myself really how to look at business
holistically and how to create and build
businesses to sell creating value that
then I began to look at you know how can
I see all of the opportunity in these
different angles in order to
you know create the most value for
myself and a lot of times under right
risk you know what I mean like if I
didn't know I was going to go and sign
that Mega television deal I wouldn't
have put into 10 million but I but then
I said well what if I go and sign this
deal how much additional Equity will you
give me for my 10 million right then
they're like oh if you go and get that
deal then we'll give you 12 extra
percent you know what I mean like then
it's like okay now I'm like you know I
just made my literally overnight made my
10 million worth like 60 million and and
underwritten it off of the deal that I'm
going and making hundreds of millions of
dollars to just do you know so it's like
you're and at the end of it and keep in
mind through all of this I work less now
than I've ever worked you know what I
mean through optimizing my time and
getting more and more efficient of how I
use it I work at at about a 40 hour week
to manage my family office all of my
Venture portfolios and shoot television
and a podcast
you know what I'm saying all of that is
without a 40-hour week you know
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
what do you think you're worth at this
point
um so you have you have liquid and you
have obviously a liquid
um what do you think the the kind of the
old the n-word the net worth is at
um and do you do you have a goal with
that and last podcast you go I need to
be a billionaire like I deserve so like
yeah where are we at remember that line
it was a beautiful line no no I don't
but that's really funny it's like I'm
you know I was doing because you got to
think like you know I have this uh in
between our last call I I had this I
hired an amazing CEO that came from a
family office structure I needed
somebody that understood business but
understood sort of the Dynamics of a
family office but was also young and
excited to go on like a a journey to a
billion dollars right and so I have
modeling for just my cash flowing assets
that take me to a billion
um like forget about like any of your
Venture stuff and building out uh sort
of your pathway through the business
side
um like I have modeling out to the year
2050 like that I have fully integrated
on all asset classes that I'm even
investing in now where do you make the
billion dollars you make it either
slowly over time time at compounding or
in big chunks right so if today I'm my
net worth of all of my assets is a
little just under 350 million right that
the the pathway uh there's the slow long
Pathway to a billion that's easy through
compounding right because because uh
just like seven or eight percent correct
right and with the the buildings now you
got to think about the way the buildings
work and the real estate work is I'm
getting five to six percent cash like a
tax-free cash but I'm still getting
seven to ten percent uh Equity growth
over the long term
um and and some of those are you know so
you know call it with the cash 15 16
irrs but a lot of the buildings that
I've uh sold I ended up with like 35 and
and 42 irrs and what do you do with that
you 10 31 exchange it and and you get
new buildings on an ongoing basis so
like that real estate even side of it
um is compounding in a unique way and
then with my cash you know money markets
are giving you five percent right now
close to five percent and then I keep uh
a significant amount of liquid dollars
in in sort of new Veen high yield funds
that kick off around a blended ten
percent that aren't going to grow but
you get cash for your cash you're making
so much cash off of your cash then
you're making so much cash a tax
depreciated cash off of your
um off of your real estate portfolio
that you you know when you look at all
of I look at that I call it the modern
cash flow portfolio where it's just that
cash is underwriting the expense of my
life in the family office right and so I
don't even like when I have these big
exits and when you know all the money I
get made from TV I look at all of it
through the lens of how much am I
actually making post-tax per hour
so okay it seems like I'm making a lot
shooting television so efficiently but
um and how much time I actually work on
the deer dick machine and the actual uh
Venture side of the business when you
look at long-term capital gains versus
ordinary income but boy when you look at
the amount of time I spend on that cash
flowing portfolio and real estate it's a
couple hours a year
and so what do you have as a as a dollar
per hour goal like what do you what is
good for you what is bad for you right
so like everybody uh has a like you know
if I do something that that saves me a
hundred dollars I go return a blender to
the store that wasn't a saving of 100 it
was it was a loss I'm looking at a
million in hours ago you know that's
your goal right as it relates to energy
and effort that's put into it right and
and you know because I I it's
fascinating when you look at how much
money I make from television and then
what that ends up being
like post tax and fees even though it
seems like a limited amount of time
because I and it's only four percent of
my time but seeing all of them through
that lens
it's a way more interesting way to view
it all you know what I mean because
since it and again it goes back to time
it's like when you because what life do
you want to live right and and where do
you get time where can you buy time back
but ultimately where are the places
where you make the most money and people
don't believe in them like this idea of
passive income uh passive income is not
buying a building that you've got to
operate and you're constantly dealing
with like trying to keep it rented and
things breaking and trying to make
decisions that's not passive income in
real estate passive income is when you
give money to an operator and they give
you cash back for your money that's when
you're doing nothing now you're you're
you what you have to get good at is
evaluating rules and and creating
principles for the type of operators
you'd be willing to deploy Capital with
so that you know that they're world
class and that you what they say they're
going to do that they do which in turn
all you're doing is reading statements
and putting a little money together or
putting a little bit of time to think
through strategy future strategy a few
times a year that's the the difference
on the way you choose to get into an
asset class you know and based off of
the last pod you you're saying how like
I I think you said I think you're 47 now
right
um You said on the last pod that
basically I think you said into your
late 30s you'd screwed a whole bunch of
[__] up I think when you're trying to
raise money from um I forget the the VC
or PE company but you're raising money
for something and you're like dude my
business sucks I'm losing money turns
out I'm I was wrong so does that mean
that like the vast majority of your real
wealth creation has been in like the 10
last 10 years
no in the last like
few years but you weren't you you were
broke I was I would consider myself
broke I would say I started from zero
almost in 2016 when I launched the
machine I wouldn't say death row I mean
you're a millionaire you you were you
worth at least ten I would say I was
probably worth like you know 15 or 20
and that's out so not broke but to me I
was like bro to a future billionaire a
millionaire is broke
well yeah but but he he described it he
was like in my 30s he's like I I spent
this this and you you said phrases like
I had nothing
but I would tell you that the majority
of this wealth was all created between
and 2022. over that four year period
right and now it's exponentially scaled
right I don't even know you know when I
think about sort of how I've I I'm I
kind of I very conservatively
um valued the ventures that get me up to
the 325 Zone I could easily push those
to I could easily say those are are you
know push me closer to four right and
but it's also like then okay what is how
do I want to continue uh to create like
bigger opportunities in the future
because I'm always like five years into
the future the same way I understood in
2016 here's the strategy the strategy
worked only it was bigger than I had
anticipated then all these other
additional things that happened I had
the clarity of like this is what I was
going to do but then that Clarity the
universe conspired to create more
opportunity that I capitalized off of
and got to this scale that I could have
never imagined in such a shorter amount
of time and all it does is make me see
further and clearer on how I can get the
scale even bigger which leads me to
believe compounding I become a
billionaire over time uh but I I believe
I can create some Ventures including the
software that I create that and the
platform that I want to build speak to
that core audience that I believe I will
be able to monetize it at a much higher
scale and a shorter amount of time with
my existing portfolio of assets and if
you Google your name you'll see like you
went on a little bit of a buying spree
where you're buying like I think four
really really nice homes in LA but I
thought it said that you I thought there
was a quote saying you're not going to
live there that's rentals
um a is that true and B what type of
real estate are you actually buying that
you consider cash flowing real estate
versus just personal yeah so I would
never buy a house of rent that's like I
didn't think so I I thought it said I I
thought it said that maybe it was like
on the what's it called like the dirt or
like the real something like that yeah
really what I did in this look this is
gonna like this will this this will give
you this is this will give you an ex
like Clarity on how much money I had
and how dumb I was in 2015.
okay I like had met like my wife
like all I wanted to find was a forever
home I had like realized in 14 like I
had began to develop like like like
learning everything about business and
everything you've got to think in 2013 I
was dumb as dirt I was at the bottom I
didn't understand business I didn't
understand anything I hired all the
consultants and all the groups and began
to formulate everything I needed to
learn to speak the way I'm speaking
today and and the strategies of what
money is where do I want to invest it
never even heard of multi-family units
in 2014 right like all of this I I then
took all of my money at the time I had
the all the money I had to my name in
2015 it was 12 million dollars in cash
moved it all to cash like because I had
money and all these different Brokers
that didn't know what it was here I am
in two thousand 15 with a vision for
like how I'm going to create a venture
Studio the deer deck machine and the
whole thing
and I'm looking for you know I just
gotten married and I'm looking for a
forever home
or a place to buy
and I find the most
heaven sent piece of land that God has
ever created in a gated community in
Beverly Hills that is a like this gated
community to a private road to a Four
Acre Promontory with unobstructed views
of the entire La Basin Hollywood Sign
ever the most extraordinary property I
have ever stepped on in my life
and paid 10 million cash for it
and then took launch this dream with two
million you know because I was like oh
Nick this is my destiny to build a house
and live on this land forever so it's
just land it was just land just land
call it forever Estates and I I have
sense and so in that neighborhood like
where it is I have bought multiple
houses and remodeled them in the
neighborhood while I continue to design
uh forever Estates as it's called and
and kept it all these years carried the
cost you know 200 Grand a year just to
carry it spending milk like built a
whole designed a whole house as an
architecture team fired them hired
sayota the best architects in the world
out of South Africa and we have just
been designing and designing and
designing it was part of the vision of
like I'm going to spend the rest of my
life in Forever Estates like that's
where I'm going to live there is no
better piece of land in the city of Los
Angeles it's the most extraordinary home
I rented a house for three and a half
years bought a house for 6.5 sold it for
like nine five two years later after
remodeling it bought another house for
for eight put two million into it this
house that I'm in now is two doors down
from the entrance to forever's Estates
so when I begin to build it uh at the in
the fall that I can be there every step
of the way but what happened begin to
build it in the fall how long ago with
timeline are we talking this has been
eight years
say to me they're like this is crazy and
I'm like man I'm going to live there
forever and when I build it I don't even
want to think about the cost it's going
to cost me 20 million to build I don't
even want to think about it I needed to
get to generational level wealth to even
like I didn't want it to be a burden
that's why I kept buying houses and kept
working on the design and then now
you've gotten to such a scale what's the
strategy now well I'm putting it into a
trust I'm paying cash for the house to
build it and then I'm going to pay rent
to the trust and then it's going to
build an endowment so that this home can
be in my family forever but run it be
self-operational that is so it doesn't
have to be tied to the estate that it
will be ran and then there can be family
meetings and forever Estates for
hundreds and hundreds of years into the
future right and you can't even get to
that way of thinking unless you have
kids unless you create generational
wealth and unless you get to that time
but that all happened
over five year period you know what I
mean that is an extraordinary transition
to get it started it started with a
horrible decision I mean 10 10. trouble
you took look I put I could have put 10
think I'm gonna say you know how many
build how much money I had invested in
buildings in 2015 100
000.
100 000 I had invested 100 000 and was
making you know seven G's from that one
and and like I put instead of putting 10
million into a cash flow which would I
would have been set for life if I were
to put that 10 million into the
buildings that I put back in 2015 that
got like 40 irrs like and we're kicking
off like nine percent cash I would have
been like set for life from the
compounding and the cash flow of that
one thing oh no oh no I took ten put it
straight into a liability do you know
what I'm saying that now I'm carrying
the cost of paying the taxes and double
homeowners fee because it's a double lot
so I'm just carrying 200 Grand a year up
and and then I'm paying all these
Architects on an ongoing basis to
continue to design and develop it
absolutely ludicrous
you're uh you're amazing are you taking
adoption I think you're 15 years older
than me you know I could be your your
teenage uh you're taking applications
yeah I want to go to Forever Estates Man
River States for you is going to be more
like a decade estate it sounds like the
way it's taken but oh that is like hey
and look even
um hey if it lasts forever what's a
decade man that's a drop in the bucket
but but think about it it seems to me
I don't even it's just another part of
seeing my life completely in
multi-dimension because it's like it's
my relationship with my wife and kids in
time it's the health that I have it's
how every part of my existence has
continued to expand and get better I
didn't get better in just business
I didn't get better in just I got better
in like all aspects of my existence on
an ongoing basis so that house if I
would have built the house I designed
five years ago I would have been so
bummed because I got every six months I
would get a completely new design get it
in VR and as I changed and thought about
and got clearer on what I wanted the
future to look like and how I would want
family meetings here in 200 years like
it allowed me to keep evolving and keep
evolving to where when I finally got to
this point where I'm just about to get
the final permits it feels
right on time to me I love that right
and and it's like I'm healthy you're
happier wealthier wiser and I know that
I'm just going to get healthier happier
um wealthier and wiser till the day that
I die and right now what's my goal one
million hours of Life
114 years and 54 days so where am I
spending a significant amount of my
wealth understanding every single aspect
of my body and having a very deep
longevity plan that allows me to to
enjoy life and live it at a high level
at the ripe old age of 112. someone get
the 114 just fall off a cliff
I uh
oh my God Rob you're amazing so I was
gonna ask you about longevity like uh
perfect segue right
yeah I want to ask about that too and
what I was going to say is very similar
to that which is like you know a lot of
people when I sold my first business and
had my first bite of like financial
success I was able to get physically fit
it was definitely a little bit easier I
could hire some people but also like I
felt a little bit more calm and I had
more time is this new focus on longevity
and focus on all this stuff is that
because you now are financially
successful and have more time or do you
think that you always had this this bug
and what are you doing now health-wise
I have been doing it Non-Stop
for as long for for 20 years I got my
first blood panel and started optimizing
into my blood work in 2012.
so for me the what where a big
transition was in 2015 around the same
time I had made the decision that like I
was in the best shape of my life but my
body was always achy and I had made this
decision that I started having a doctor
come to my house five days a week and
all I wanted to do was build a perfectly
structured physical system
and there was no timeline to it and
really what it led to is triangulating a
ton of different therapies which in but
in the process allowed me to learn every
muscle in my body how the fascist system
works what are my neurological
deficiencies what are all of the things
that I need to retrain in My overall
system internally as it relates to leaky
gut and blood brain barrier all of these
sort of things that lead to inflammation
that lead to to heart disease and all
these different things that that reduce
your quality and length of life I had
been doing over a decade so now the way
I approach it is so sophisticated
because I know every single aspect of my
entire function holistically of my body
my mind my time my energy
so it's a different level so what
happened when I got to this scale of
success I referred to it as Peak top
it's the same psychological uh chaos
that happens to a drug addict at Rock
Bottom where like you finally make a
truth in you where like you don't you
can't be a drug addict anymore and
something shifts in you mentally I
finally got to I'm I it happened to me
on the other side
where like you've started getting more
and more disciplined and healthy that
you all of a sudden were like
why would I ever not just be
extraordinarily healthy for the rest of
my life and what happened from that
point I have not missed the day of
getting up at 5am I have not missed a
day in the gym I have not missed one day
meditating I have not missed one day
eating supplements eating clean I have
not had a drink I haven't had any sugar
I haven't had a snack any of that for
since I hit that like nine months ago
the data that I shared with you guys as
it relates to the quality of my Life
numbers how I feel about my life work
and health zero to ten and then my
discipline numbers what percentage did I
get up at five brain train meditate get
in the gym eat clean and not drink and
take my supplements it is one hundred
percent across this entire year and then
my qualitative numbers are at the
highest they've ever been so every
single day
I wake up feeling extraordinary
right and I grew into that and then the
more success I had if I didn't have to
then decide I want to be healthy I had
been working when in 2016 when I
designed my vision for my business and
my financial success I designed a vision
for my life success and my health
success so what happened over the last
seven years is I got better and better
and better at all of it which led to
this euphoric state of where you have an
incredible depth of knowledge of your
entire reality and your current state
and your future state so you're just
continuously predicting the future and
creating higher probabilities of being
healthier happier and wealthier in the
future while
living extraordinary in the present
what's been like the the 80 20 of that
like the the the things that have made
the biggest change on your health
I mean look you I you not drinking not
eating sugar and intermittent fasting
and eating a lean uh protein and
vegetable meal to me is everything
is everything because you're just your
body begins to clean itself you feel
better about yourself you make sharper
decisions you go two layers deeper your
emotions are more in check like things
happen inside the family different
things that are uncontrollable you're
able to like like control all of those
better that just pure diet alone in
avoiding all of these like like
processed foods and and alcohol like in
being committed to that will absolutely
change your life because it gives your
mind more depth to to be able to execute
at a higher amount at a higher level in
the limited amount of time that you have
to execute
sorry have you seen this guy Brian
Johnson what he's doing look I look at
Brian Johnson as this guy's outrageous
it's too much but I with all my judgment
because I'm our like if I would have
told myself five years ago hey this is
what you're gonna be doing I'll be like
that guy's crazy so I look at man I I
feel like Brian Johnson's crazy but I'll
probably turn into Brian Johnson in like
seven or eight years yeah he's wild man
he's wild yeah Brian Johnson just has
that look you know what I mean he looks
like a futuristic like amoeba you know
what I mean that's what I was thinking I
looked at him the other day I'll go all
he needed all he needs to do is tan if
he Tans everybody be like this guy is
amazing he doesn't tan and they're like
you're you're a vampire bro
just he looks like AI all like the new
AI versions of people like coming out he
looks like an AI person he might not
even be real he might not be able to be
real
he's a mid-journey but I do look at like
that aspect because you've got to think
about anything think about the way that
I talk about business it's knowledge and
experience and an understanding and then
a continual Evolution and growth of
understanding the whole like applying
that to my relationship with my wife and
family applying that to my health
applying that to business applying that
to investment implying that to building
my my family office like all of that way
of thinking like is is based off of
gaining knowledge to take something from
not understanding it feeling difficult
to then making it easier then
continually optimizing right you're just
incrementally making it all better
what what are I love the way you think
and I love the kind of pursuit of
greatness and pursuit of Excellence for
yourself and having a vision for
yourself
um I also know that it's inspiring but
also hard to relate to Perfection and so
I'm curious what are the current flaws
or bugs in your software that you're
still debugging we all have some bugs in
our software that's running we're we're
hunting them down and we're trying to
squash them one at a time what are some
that are still still in your your system
it might be in business it might be in
Hell might be in you know for me oh you
know
a nice bag of chips it's still a bug in
my software uh you know maybe something
oh sometimes when I'm with my wife I'm
not as present as I should be I'm on my
phone but I know that's not really me
and who I'm gonna be but I'm still
catching up to myself in that way what
are some of those for you
you know and this is gonna sound like
extraordinarily
um don't say it I tried to help you man
I tried to serve you up a way to be
vulnerable here no no I'm not I'm not uh
no again I'm not there is no
yeah no no I'm not there is no like to
me it is like I still get triggered like
and we'll get angry right like I will
get like when my expectations are
mismanaged at a high level I'll I'll get
mad and get like in snap right like I
have I'm not even kidding you like I am
trying to like like even when I get
triggered I'm trying to stop the
triggers
um to avoid like saying something like
letting it come out right like I'm
really but I still feel the trigger my
goal is to get to like don't even let
things trigger you like when you let
people get angry but you gotta think
part of like the evolution is like
there's certain people in your life that
do that to me that I had to let go of
right and continually optimize for those
people and this is the this is embedded
in my soul
this is embedded in my soul when I feel
stuck
when I feel stuck when I'm working on
like trying to do deep work or doing and
I feel stuck
all I want
is pizza and wine
all I want is pizza and wine it's not
even like a matter of like
like acting on it it's like my soul
feels like it needs it needs a glass of
like wine and it's like because whenever
I get stuck it's this this psychological
thing of like just [__] let it all go
let it all go so even though I don't act
on it because I've just evolved Beyond
it I still when I get stuck I the
feelings are are exist in there but but
I'm telling you it's the
you know
the commitment of where it went 100
health and no alcohol and no sugar in
that level it eliminated so many things
it eliminated me being like you know
short with people it eliminated me like
making rash decisions right not thinking
through stuff and just like shooting
from the hip you know which is a
recovery you know I used to say like you
know deer deck Enterprises are money
Fearless right because I would uh and
like invest so recklessly when it was
really our money's dumb but that
Reckless like let's just push it forward
like let's just let's just start it and
go for it is still something that I
fight on an ongoing basis because I'll
get excited and energized and see it and
be like let's do it and I've got to
control that impulse just to that I've
that I've learned to control in this
state at a much higher level but there
are very little and here's the thing I I
look at it as like how Kobe was never
like was relatable to me because it was
too much discipline and how Tom Brady
like man why would you not take the off
season off like like I used to look at
that as this impossible level and to
mean
like I know that I'm I'm reaching this
unrelatable unattainable place it's why
I put out a podcast uh earlier this year
that was the most unrelatable podcast
part one and part two because I just
laid out the depth of like actually how
I'm operating and what I've learned
along the way to get to this level
because I do want to
I want to be the proof that you can get
to a place where you never get angry you
never have a negative thought where you
are completely harmonious and balanced
in all your relationships and time and
health and happiness where you are happy
and filled with gratitude seven days a
week every single day ever even under
unexpected duress I I'm living in and I
know it's possible I want to continue to
be proof that it is then I want to build
the product services and tools that
other people can use to get to this
level and this feeling because to me it
is heaven on Earth it is true happiness
is really the output of this existence
that I've created in a relatively short
amount of time
let me uh let me run this trend by you
guys that I'm seeing and it's related to
this so I live part of the time in New
York part of the time most of the time
in Austin Texas and I also owed a ranch
out in Texas and what I'm noticing is
that in Austin it's almost like La a
little bit where we have all types of
Health freaks you know it's like it's
really cool to be around those types of
people and I eat really healthy as well
and I'm noticing that my extreme help
friends they're doing something like
that like a redneck family like where I
grew up what they used to do which is
they buy a cow so like you like go in
with either you or your neighbor and you
go and purchase a cow and someone
Slaughters it and then you get like the
whole cow for the year and I noticed
that Zuckerberg I think two years ago he
made this commitment that he was only
going to eat what he killed or I think
even grew and I'm noticing that my
health friends are doing this now and
I've seen a lot of tweets recently where
people saying like you know I'm eating
healthy but I still feel bad but when I
go to Europe I feel good and I did some
research there's the FDA and the
European the EU how they like measure
food it's a little bit differently like
the the preservatives and things anyway
have you I know you're into Health now
and I know you invest in a lot of Health
and Wellness stuff my prediction is that
in the next five or ten years I think
we're going to see a couple Brands where
you can buy meat online I'm even seeing
people like revolt against like Whole
Foods meat have you are you eating and
so it's like something I've been
thinking about is me have you been do
you eat just meat off the shelf from
Whole Foods or do you get it from
somewhere special because I think
there's going to be an interesting brand
that does this the next five or ten
years yeah look like
I
my meat
is not so special to me
I when I and so how I do it how do I do
it I get
um meal delivery seven days a week right
and I get from which brand uh it's just
a local Chef here
so I get that's all organic right
grass-fed and so I get a grass-fed beef
yeah yeah so it tastes so bad man yeah
and and so look so so to me I'm that's
my Baseline and then I have breakfast
Wednesdays with my wife I have Friday
night pasta with my wife Sunday night
Sushi like I have sort of the rhythm of
dates that I take my wife on and so when
I look at that particular protein if you
will at this stage like I'm I look at
that as as as as much as I'm willing to
dedicate into what's in my body until I
can get to a point where the data shows
me the impact of having Daisy in the
backyard and me cutting Daisy up and
slicing off a rib is going to deliver
more nutrients that's going to add to a
a longer uh higher quality of life I
would need the data to take me there one
day as opposed to getting that nuanced
and the delivery of the quality of that
protein where at this point for me
that's enough as it relates to what I'm
capable and my personal capacity can
dedicate to the quality of the food you
know I think this is going to be a thing
Sean if you don't know there's a company
that just raised money from Peter Thiel
it's called Coop and they're making the
Tesla of chicken coops so normal people
could have a chicken coop in their
backyard have you guys that shot I'll
believe any Trend yeah the cat Coop guy
he's the I crack guy right same guy yeah
AJ dude I'm so fascinated with this look
listen listen right now fundamentally
would you have your own chickens that
you slaughtered and ate chickens if it
was no it's for the eggs it's it's for
the eggs yeah it's for the eggs eggs bro
you you just told me that a shower head
company is going to be worth billion
okay and you just bought a 10 million
dollar piece of land when so look you
might have an error in your judgment
things happen
like I I know your biggest weakness is
you sick of the shower but come on yeah
look for eggs maybe the beef I you know
I but I don't know I'm not I don't I'm
not you guys when you look at Trends on
an ongoing basis you you refine your
lens of like the things that were
improbable that ended up working when
they're harder to see you know what I
mean I I think Maya even lens is is
always ties back to the probability of
the unit economics and the reoccurring
Revenue aspect of it you know like I
look at it so much more through that
lens because even when I think about the
coupe right if you're selling a single
unit Hardware uh now you've got this
incredibly small
um
like like customer base in the very
beginning that are the ultra healthy and
then they're they're it's like a a
mattress like in the direct to Consumer
mattress game as soon as they buy one
they don't need another one for for you
know 15 years right like it's it's would
suffer that same sort of consequence
versus five years ago Coop would get you
know 100 million dollar valuation based
off of like there's gonna be coups in
every house in the world it's Innovation
it's like the Tesla of eggs you know so
right My Lens isn't as refined and I
always go back to like like how much
revenue the idea could create from a
long-term value perspective
um versus those those tough uh Hardware
businesses that are minimal margin and
you sell one you know so what what
trends interest you now where what do
you think's gonna be popular in the next
five years and where you investing your
money for uh what interesting Trends are
you looking to invest in yeah look I
don't invest in anything I invest in
real estate and and businesses that I
create and right now I haven't even uh
invested in a new Venture since Jolie
um you know because to me I'm I do think
when I look out into the future like
like as it relates to the type of stuff
that I would do would still be related
to biofeedback
um you know Health customization all of
these things that that help lead you uh
to optimizing your overall health and
well-being
um you know I do think you know uh like
you know you got to think those those
glucose monitors that have that sort of
come out to kind of give you an
indication of like what your blood sugar
is doing when you're eating food
um that they're going to evolve that to
eventually become dopamine and cortisol
and it's going to end up being a
Cornerstone of like how you even your
life is actually feeling based off of
what your your blood is saying in real
time I think that's going to be
something that really makes a big impact
on the world
um and and to me I wanna I wanna time
into creating the existence management
system that helps you manage how all of
it fits together to lead to your present
moment in time and help you optimize for
guiding your life to creating higher
energy present moments that you use with
purpose and whether that's to to be on
your phone and watch TV with your wife
because you're tired or it's
um for you to be ultra present with your
kids so that you can actually experience
it or you want to be able to design use
the present to design a better future
for yourself like it's really about how
do you become this healthy develop
healthy and understanding in the
knowledge of yourself develop the ultra
awareness of everything about you so
that you can continually live a
consistent state of Joy because feeling
Joy over long periods of time is what it
creates the feeling of happiness
so we could wrap up with whatever you
want to but I know the people in the
comments are gonna be like why is that
douchebag bringing up me what the [__]
they're already good I already know
they're gonna flame me in the YouTube
comments
yeah I was just curious Rob uh I wanted
you to can you can you finish with the
two-minute crash course on something
I've been uh look interested in and you
know very well which is production
companies so I noticed uh I don't know
anything about Hollywood or TV
production but I I my ears perked up
when uh I forgot who was they bought um
Reese Witherspoon's production company
for some hundreds of millions of dollars
then uh I saw that Peter chernin from
The churning group he's doing a roll-up
of production companies he's put in a
billion dollars to work rolling up
production companies and I thought oh
that's interesting I read some
interviews and he's talking about why he
thinks there's a you know growing and
sort of insatiable demand for content
and then uh you know I just look at
people who create Netflix shows I go
look at uh you know oh love is blind
this ranked number one on Netflix who
created this I was a small production
company like is this like the startup
game where you create the next hit show
and you become a billionaire or is it a
ruthless business can you just just
describe what creating a show or
creating a production company is like
and if that's a good business to be in
or not
as someone who
um sold their production company for 200
million and who like had an offer on the
table
um
that fell apart for 400 million recently
it is the worst business that you could
ever get in in your life this is like
and I'll explain to you why it is a
shoot which you kill game and the
Distributors control all of the money so
like in your you have a hit show and you
have this flourishing production company
and then the show gets canceled and your
company's worth zero right it is and
then the problem with shows is like they
don't pick them up for long periods of
time I have a five-year 1680 episode
order of Television it is unprecedented
in all of production it does not exist
but why is it hard for me to turn around
and sell that because it's one single
show and now they look at the and it's
so expensive because it's made the
production company so profitable but
let's just say that didn't push you away
a production company is built like this
right you
you've got to build the infrastructure
that allows you to have your camera
equipment your finishing equipment your
licensing for your music you've got to
basically then go and and give a budget
to a network who's going to give you 500
grand for an episode and now you have
got to figure out how to pull uh 20 to
30 percent of that in margin right so it
gets in incredibly difficult to do and
the only way that you can do that is
look at all of the different ways that
you can scrape margin out of that budget
by owning vertically integrated so a lot
of times there'll be people that that
you know have
um you know television shows and they
just get paid an executive producer fee
right so they will make a lot of money
like Jeff Tremaine uh who is one of the
executive producers on my show you know
makes millions off of ridiculousness and
doesn't just off his executive producer
fee nothing where we rolled in our
executive producer fees then built out
the entire post and finishing and music
division to push our margins up to be
able to to create a sellable asset then
we had multiple shows and then the
um you know the
call it the
long-term sustainability of
ridiculousness created the value that
allowed us to sell it right and so even
if you you launch an a production
company and you have love is blind and
it's a hit show you're not making that
much money off of that show you are now
hoping to stack shows and then end up
pulling off of that margin that you get
to split right and then then you trade
on ebitda right so when you sell the
business you're trading at like you know
six times ebitda five six times ebitda
and then a lot of times now they won't
even buy you outright they will partner
with you incentivize your long-term earn
out because they don't want to just like
pay you you know five times six times
your ebitda and then all of a sudden
like the show goes away right they and
and you were the creative force behind
getting new shows right so it's a lot
more
like complex and when you think about
like the big dogs doing it they're
looking at it more from they're buying
the creative minds that are making the
new content all the time so when you if
they believe long term in content
they're just and when you look at that
aggregate you can have a couple of them
slip and have a couple heroes in there
and when you see all those together you
can bet that that thing's gonna generate
a ton of cash because the industry
itself is built around being incredibly
lean and then
um being being profitable because
they're only worth their profitability
and then they can accordion you got a
Big Show and all this stuff and the show
goes away boom you bring it all the way
back down because you you put so many
people under under the show itself so
that's where the bigger vision is for
them to look at and is there an
opportunity
um
for creatives and people in the space in
this day yes because endeavor's doing it
churnan's doing it a lot of people are
doing it but it's extraordinarily
difficult and and The Gatekeepers are
the Distributors the Netflix the
paramounts the you know you can attempt
to create your own platform and
distribute It Yourself YouTube digitally
whatever it is but it's expensive and
difficult to build audiences and then
you're really looking at those
Distributors as The Gatekeepers to the
quality of the asset that you're
creating and whether or not someone will
make it to decide that you're worth the
purchase all of that
incredibly difficult in my opinion to to
make happen you know
perfect answer exactly I was looking for
Rob this has been amazing one somehow uh
where should people follow up where do
you want we want it on your pod your
Twitter email list how can people get
more rob you know Rob's just at Rob
Dyrdek a cross-social you know on a.com
and just you know I got billed with Rob
but really I'm not out pitching nothing
I'm just out trying to figure it out
keep evolving but one day
I'm gonna come back on with my software
when it's done well first I'm gonna send
it to you guys first and and then when
the book and the philosophy are out and
the software is out then it's gonna be
like how do we convert the listeners
into changing their lives from being
erratic in the harmonious high quality
existences with the existence operating
system you know but that's off in the
future now I'm just glad to reconnect
because I'm thankful for you guys
um
for kind of starting the spark of the
whole thing and really I'm even thankful
for you posting all the data and using
the customer acquisition from the stuff
that I sent you you know I sent you all
the new stuff so you know you know what
happened Sam man I know so basically he
came on he did the rhythm of existence
he sent us the the Excel PDF we post on
Twitter and it was kind of over and then
like a year later I was like all right
I'm gonna start building my email list
and I was like um how do I get fans of
the show The the like-minded people how
do I get my type of people to subscribe
I don't just want any subscriber I want
the right type of person I was like what
would the right type of person be into
and I was like oh dude the Rob the Rob
Dyrdek the that that rhythm of existence
sheet the time tracker I think they
would be nerding out about that like
that's my type of nerd and so we put it
up as a lead magnet which was like hey
come you know put your email in and get
the he'll share his uh thing with you
and uh we start spending a bunch of
money and Rob emails me like I don't
know six months ago he's like bro you're
blowing me up with this sheet you know
it's all good but you got to update the
photo you're using the wrong photo from
from over here and so we updated the
photo and I was like oh man I feel bad
we take the whole ad down we start
putting something else up but it was a
it was a moment of embarrassment don't
feel bad because it it to me just
perpetuates like like for me it just
continues to push The Narrative of like
level of discipline and commit and data
driven so and Rob you said well you said
you subscribed it was good in that we we
we're preaching your gospel and it makes
you look like a badass so there's
nothing bad there I just should have
asked you first and I had forgotten to
do that I didn't do that and that's why
I felt yes I was like oh my bad yeah
don't hey I appreciate it and thought it
was funny but I was also like like this
is great then I was like interested in
the data from your perspective of like
okay well I wonder how many it converted
just to kind of understand like how many
well there was nothing to convert to
right like since you had the DocuSign it
was just the views of the uh the the PDF
was like what I was interested in right
and yeah I don't think it ran for too
long I think it had maybe five thousand
ten thousand hits something like that
yeah so you know a good amount for sure
but um yeah and again I love that as
just another data point from my
perspective that's why I was like Hey
use the new stuff make you feel more
inviting like make it feel more exciting
for people to see it to because I want
to you know continue to lead to
perpetuate it but again
Rob's getting triggered now by the way
this is him working on that trigger of
not getting angry yeah I was talking to
somebody yesterday about triggers they
were like they're like man he just
pushes my buttons and I was like dude
you're like a Blackberry you're just
covered in buttons I was like you the
problem is not that he push a button
you've got so many buttons to push like
you want to be an iPhone no buttons
nothing to push what can someone do to
you now you're unstoppable okay and it's
possible for everybody to get there
awesome well we appreciate this dude uh
last time maybe video and audio had like
half a million views I have feeling this
is gonna uh crush it so we appreciate
you okay till we meet again till we meet
again see you guys thank you
[Music]
foreign